i think what you're going to see is once
we take over and we will take over the
house in january there's no question
about it and i think leader mccarthy has
stated that he's going to uh obviously
form some select committees i think
we'll be looking in the hunter's laptop
and and covet issues afghanistan that
dismal withdrawal and and obviously the
southern border fentanyl so i think
there's going to be some communities
established i think that judiciary and
oversight and government reform are
going to be very very busy uh for the
next two years just looking at some of
these things but as it relates to the
529 i'm not certain uh but i i you know
it it's sad i mean january 6 was a
difficult day i was one of the last guys
there uh you know uh protecting that
chamber having actually conversations
with the individuals on the other side
so
it just said and i think the american
people look at that it was a black eye
on america i mean we got to be clear is
a black guy but it it was not donald
trump that brought those people inside
that
i got a tough question for you yeah
will you support the impeachment of joe
biden after the republicans take over
the house without question yeah there
you go without a question i thought it
was going to be a hard one no no it
wouldn't be and it wouldn't change i was
in fact the easiest question
no my orcas needs to go you need to get
rid of some of these others because i've
been down to the southern border i'm
going to go deflect down to the southern
border but i've been down there my orc
is telling the american people the
southern border is closed no it's not
i'm down here in the water with griff
jenkins from fox news and there's people
walking right across so don't tell me
and don't stop lying to the american
people
uh sorry i think he should be impeached
over ukraine i think you guys need to
launch an investigation into those
dealings it's remarkable how donald
trump got impeached
over uh
well he was impeached over ukraine great
i believe right that was that was one
yeah the phone call was kicking into
what biden was doing and it was it was
it was clever
the the democratic establishment and
obviously the neocon republicans who
work with them
were able to take what joe biden did
stick it to trump and use it to impeach
him they said donald trump engaged in a
quid pro quo with the president of
ukraine when what actually happened was
in my opinion when you listen when you
see the transcript and you hear about
what trump was saying it sounds like
trump didn't really know what was going
on it sounds like trump watched fox news
and then saw some video where joe
biden's like i said you're not getting a
loan guarantee a billion dollars unless
you fire the prosecutor well sob guy get
fired and then trump's like what's going
on and then he calls him and he's like
what was that but but free look at the
transcript he's like what was that video
about and he's like look into it and
that was it and they were like impeach
him why
joe biden
went to ukraine
when the us government approved a
billion dollars in loan guarantees
he told ukraine and bragged about it by
the way
if you don't fire the prosecutor victor
shoken i will block these loans and the
president of ukraine told joe biden you
can't do that you don't have the
authority and biden said call the
president see what he says the man
admitted to having no authority
to to acquit pro quo gloated about it
laughed in a room full of people
turns out victor shokan had a dozen plus
investigations into burisma
where hunter biden said on the board
getting 83 000 per month
now i'm not accusing joe biden of having
done that for the purpose of protecting
his son i'm saying it just so happens
the prosecutor was investigating a
company his son worked at made a lot of
money from here's the best part
according to hunter biden's laptop they
shared bank accounts so that means the
money that was coming into hunter biden
joe biden had access to they also shared
phone numbers i look at that and i'm
just like how do we not have an
investigation at the very i'm not saying
joe biden's guilty i'm saying that's
beyond probable cause to be like maybe
we should investigate what happened here
i'm just realizing me and my father are
not as close as we should be
that sounds awesome
but this i mean and that's exactly why
the media covered it up right that's
exactly why it was suppressed by all the
major social media companies we we we've
we've had other uh republican prospects
you know i've asked about this i'm like
well you know when it comes to
impeachment we're going to need this
that you're just like we're doing it
i really appreciated that actually no
issues with that at all hey can i quite
honestly we got to wait till i mean i
really want him to be the democrat
nominee in 20 you know i was just going
to say
we need sleepy joe to be there i saw you
try to run and pick him up when he fell
off his bike just like come on buddy you
got this you got this yeah can i i just
want to backtrack to january 6th because
i actually think it's really interesting
and i've obviously i've never talked to
anyone who was there where
you're republican so you're on the side
of a lot of the people who are there
you're from law enforcement so you have
to gauge and assess threats and protect
people um i i assume even when you are
not wearing that badge you still take
that um very seriously what in god's
name was your
mindset during that like what what what
were you
thinking what was the mentality did you
really
feel threatened were you in law
enforcement mode were you in like what
is this political you know did you take
it lightly what was going on through
your head
great question jb it was covered so it's
not like they were all 435 of us on the
floor right there were many up in the up
in the in the gallery area as well and i
was there back towards the center on the
right side and the center and we were
going through the objectives of arizona
and then all of a sudden you know
there's no televisions on the house
floor they've got some in the cloakrooms
in the back but then all of a sudden i
started getting some text messages and
stuff from family and friends and then
all of a sudden i saw a bunch of capitol
police rush in uniform non-uniform yeah
and then one guy said the capital has
been breached capital's been breached
we're locked in we're not going anywhere
so i'm back at the back there and
there's they're trying to get members
out and then all of a sudden they
started banging on those center doors so
if you see pictures of me in that blue
shirt i'm that guy in that blue shirt
you're like this is white house down
it's happening and then all of a sudden
they they broke the windows they broke
the windows and then it got a little bit
ugly yeah yeah yeah did you know who at
this point were you in just defensive
mode were you trying to figure it out no
i didn't know i mean i i all i did do
know is that that that some others put
some furniture in front of those doors
to make sure that they wouldn't get
through yeah uh they broke the windows
and then i was eyeballing a kid on the
other side a young man
and then i started having a little
conversation with him because you see in
all these pictures these capital police
officers have their guns drawn right and
and so i thought we cannot have this i
mean people are going to get shot if
we're not careful so my job my law
enforcement background trying to diffuse
the situation yeah and we did it and and
and nobody entered uh the capital police
said you got to get off the house floor
i said i'm not leaving i'm not leaving
my brothers and sisters in blue so i
stayed there till the end cool
good for you
that's it not not worried about
i mean
were you worried at all about your
safety like your life no my wife's a
little upset but there's the picture
remember what kind of booth jordan
do you see that guy yeah yeah
yeah i mean to be fair me and uh the
congressman almost had a wrestling match
downstairs before the show and i was
like i trust this guy can handle himself
we spotted each other's cauliflower here
you saw my ear jamie you said i you
backed off i spotted the threat before
you spotted my ears and then you were
like oh boy and then we became friends
that's great
yeah this is uh this is it right yes
yeah hey look at that that's me my wife
said god baby i didn't know you were
that receding that much at ball there
but no we were i tell you i applaud the
capitol police officers they're with me
though i mean they did a good job they
maintained composure they did not fire
when that glass was broken and initially
we thought it was gunfire because i'm
i'm ducked on it wow and then
immediately within seconds there was
another guy said i don't think that was
gunfire because they'd hit me i mean
i wouldn't be here today one officer did
fire
well and that was about probably 10-15
minutes after that photo yeah um and
that was off my back right shoulder in
the in the speaker's lobby and that was
lieutenant byrd and i've been a very
vocal critic of that shooting i've had
officers shot and killed and and i've
had officers shoot and kill people uh so
i know a little bit about uh you know
self-defense and use of force and and he
he should have been charged with that he
never went to a grand jury ashley
babbitt was murdered in our nation's
capital on january 6. will there be an
effort on the do you believe on the part
of republicans or yourself to to
investigate or to to get an indictment
or anything like that well i would like
to i think we need to continue to talk
about but i don't think there's going to
be a lot of energy
to move down that path i've been one of
maybe two or three or four uh
in the house that is actually address
this issue we we tend to like the
freedom caucus you know you look at uh
right now with
most republicans and it's like they just
want to get by they want to they want to
they want to do the bare minimum just
get by get through the next day they'll
forget about it when they forget about
it right now one of the big issues
that's really got me fired up is uh
so i'm a resident of west virginia
that's where i officially live and uh
shelley moore capito the senator
republican has signed on to this gun
control legislation and she's a
republican in west virginia second most
trump supporting state in the country so
i'm i'm a little bit upset about that
and that's the problem we had we have 14
republicans in the senate supporting
this ridiculous bill
so
coming to the the aid of democrats who
want to strip strip us off our rights
you know what bothers me is we never see
the inverse we never see democrats being
forced to negotiate with republicans on
easing gun gun uh gun restrictions and
bringing about gun access so that really
you know i don't know that that
hurts me i mean republicans are expected
to
hold the line and compromise a little
bit and then hold the line at its new
position whenever a republican actually
tries to bring things back to the way
they used to be or conserve as
conservatives are supposed to they're
called an extremist or a radical
yeah
well
i don't know what what are your thoughts
on the gun stuff you're right there are
14 senators and and one of our senators
we have two obviously uh from texas uh
john cornyn and ted cruz and i know that
uh john cornyn i think mcconnell asked
him to kind of help lead that effort and
try to find some unity or compromise uh
uh with it with the other side one of
the democrats yeah well i'm just letting
you know that uh corner we had a uh
our big state convention was last week
and senator cornyn spoke at it and they
booted him up pretty much right out of
the room so i think he's he's having a
difficult time right now i mean uh
they're liars
shelly capito said that uh we
this is not about red flag laws we won't
allow that the bill's literally got a
whole section on red flag laws and
funding it they just they're just
spitting in our faces and then telling
us it's raining what do you think um
and i'm asking all of these serious
questions maybe because i'm surrounded
by ian's crystals and i'm trying to
bring unity uh to the country but
what are your thoughts on
i feel like democrats and republicans
they
never come together to talk about hey
how can we together
help with these shootings these mass
shootings or what can we do to prevent
them or what are better law enforcement
tactics obviously we just saw a complete
disaster happen in texas and what ends
up happening is it becomes we want to
take all your guns don't take my guns
and we stop talking about people's
safety right and so you again coming
from law enforcement i feel like
whenever republicans on the news
are asked about what we should do we're
not they don't really get asked about
tactics they just
have to automatically be on their heels
and defend you know
the second amendment essentially so do
you see any
sort of compromise or what would you do
with your experience um
about the shootings while maintaining
the second amendment like are is there
anything you think needs to change when
it comes to gun control gun legislation
or do you think it's more a mental
health thing etcetera etcetera i think
mental illness is a serious issue in our
country uh quite honestly just look at
everything you see on television today
it seems to be a little bit weird but
nobody wants to see what took place in
uvalde nobody
we all hurt if you have children you
it's it's painful to watch it i don't
even quite honestly like even talking
about it yeah but when you talk about
these red flag laws and if you look at
there's 19 states i believe that have
red flag laws in our country and some of
those states are illinois and in in new
york and here in district at columbia
washington d.c and they have those red
flag laws and they're very they're some
of the most strict gun laws you can have
in the country it talks about waiting
periods and and keeping guns out of the
mentally ill and domestic abusers and
even talking about private sales
transaction 72 hour waiting periods so
they're all there
limits on how you could buy ammo and
they have some of the highest crime in
the country so i'm saying if chicago
listen gore lightfoot whatever her name
is if you can find a way to solve the
problems i mean people are killing each
other but nobody's talking about the
people being killed in chicago i
actually actually do have a very simple
proposal that uh will maintain the
second amendment rights and uh reduce
these shootings
promote fathers in the home
i'm not kidding that's literally the
answer the the profile of most of these
mass shooters it's no fatherlessness
uh
that's that's like a huge issue crime
outside of the mass shooting incident
incidents you look at crime in chicago
for instance it's a lack of a father in
the home so we we need to encourage at
the very least two parent homes we need
we need dads we need moms
i mean what's so frustrating hearing
both of you guys is that
you know when i lived in the very rugged
neighborhood of park slope brooklyn i
you know all of my friends had never
shot a gun were all very vocal anti-gun
anti-gun anytime there was a shooting we
would essentially just assume any
republican would rather we'll play with
their toy guns and like save children's
lives because we didn't know anyone we
never shot a gun and then i moved to
texas and my friends were like hey man
you want to shoot a gun i was like this
is awesome and but i actually started
asking questions to green berets to navy
seals to firearms instructors and
i'm 40 years old and it was the first
time in my life and i had a political
talk show it was my job and it was the
first time in my life i even heard
statistics like hey it's not that we're
against these laws if these laws worked
maybe we would talk about these laws but
i'm literally just learning for the
first time that like nah man they don't
even work and in fact some of the places
that are the most heavily armed are the
safest thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there